よろしくお願いします
まあ今日はこのただ一つの言葉
このあり合わせという言葉に集中して
仏教の世界を紹介したいと思います
今日は色合わせがあまり良くなくて
読めない可能性あります
あの えーと まあテーマは草の束なんです
で これからこの問答に挑戦してみてください
草の束は美味しいですか？と
どうですかね イエスでしょうか
ノーでしょうか ということで
ちょっと真剣に考えてください
イエスならあなたは草を食べる人間になるんです
おいしいと言っちゃうと
自分が草食べている人間ということを認めることになります
ノーならあなたは草を食べる人間か
食べたことがある人間になるんです
どうやっておいしくないと言えますかね
食べたことがなければ
あるいはそっちを草を食べる人間でなければ
では 答えは何ですかね
どちらでもないなら あなたは草を食べる人間になる
おいしくもまずくもどちらでもないという立場をとったらどうなるんですかね
ということは 食べたことはあるという話でしょうに
ということは まあ毎日草を食べていて
別においしいとまずいとも何でもないんだと
毎日食べてる じゃあ答えは何ですかね
イエスかノーか どちらでもないかですかね
わかりません は 自分が無知であることを認めるんですよ
わかりませんと言っちゃうと
アホということですね
どうせ無知な人の質問が出せませんだからね
しかし 正解があるとするならば
その正解は でも私は今正解があるんですよ
草の束はおいしいですかという質問に正解があるんです
わかりませんでも ノーでもイエスでもどちらでも言うと嵌められます
では 正解は何ですかね
仮に答えはこういうふうに答えにしておきましょう
一応これは答えなんです
で まあこれから勉強に入ります
あの 2種類あります 答えは一つはコンディショナルということは
2番目はアンコンディショナルということで
あの まあコンディショナルリプライ
アンコンディショナルリプライという 2つあります
で説明していきます コンディショナル回答は複数あります
コンディショナルという
これは専門英語で使ってますけど
まあただ条件付きというぐらいの意味で理解してください
まああまり条件付きというぐらいの軽いものでもないんですけど
コンディショナルというのは
で 条件付き 答えるならば複数の答えがあるんです
人間には草が美味しくはない
ヤギやら牛などの動物には草がおいしいというね
これ別にイエスでもノーでもない答えでしょ
わかりませんという答えでもないでしょ
で これコンディショナルですよ
条件 人間という条件をつけちゃうと
もうおいしくないんです
山羊やまあ牛とか条件をつけてみるとおいしいと
草は餌にしている生命においしいでしょうということなんですね
でもその中でもまあ私たちはまたまた疑問も作りますけど
まあ一応まあその程度でいいと思って
まあ一応軽く手を打ったんです
で 私にこの答え出しちゃうとまずいんです
それも潰します まあ一応その程度にしましょう
もしそちらにある欠点見つかるならば
どうぞ言ってください
まあ結構頭いいっていうことになります
草は食べ物にならない
生命にはこの問答は成り立たないんですよ
管轄外なんです だから
それって一つの大事な答えなんです
私に草の束美味しいでしょうか？というと
それは私の管轄外ですよと
例えばね 海の中で生まれて生活することはどんなものか知るものか
そんなのは管轄外でしょうね
それさえ知らない人々は
もうすぐイエスかノーか言おうとしてハメられるんです
だからこれ管轄外ということは答えなんです
ノットレラントという英語で言えばね
草を噛んでみて 例えばそれでも人間に美味しいですか？って聞いたら
ちょっと調べますと言って噛んでみることはできますよ
でも草を食べたということは
もう一応その味はありますけど
まあそれでも実験のためにね
まあどうしようもないし
噛んでみると 噛んでみると
答えが 3つ出てくるんです
その噛んだ人にとっては
1 美味しい  2 マズい  3 どちらでもないというね
まあどうったことはないんだと
まあ温度はどうったことないんで
味は それであれはコンディショナルリプライというか
条件付きの答えのいくつか答えがあるでしょ
覚えました いくつかありますね
まあ草餌にしている動物にとっては美味しいとと言ったって
あんたどうやって知ってるのかと聞きたくなりますけどね
で 草を餌にしない生命にとってはまずいと
餌にならない 食用にならないというね
場合はまずいですと 人間にそんなのを聞いたら
答えは管轄外っていう答えになる
だからまあそちらでも答え 3つが成り立って
この下を見るとまた 3つが成り立ちますね
ということで もう６種類が答えがあるんです
それ条件付き場合なんです
じゃあ条件が付かないアンコンディショナル答えは何でしょうか？と
条件が付く必要はない
回答に達するために まず分析しなくてはならないんですよ
答えも６つあると困るでしょうに
あなたの身長はどれぐらいですかって言ったら ６
つありますよと これ話にならんでしょうに
皆様と同じくなるんです
何か聞いちゃうともう話にならん
答えは そうじゃなくて
質問には答えあるはずなんです
たくさんあるはずがないんです
このテーブルの形はなんでかって
まあもういくつかありますよと
丸いとオーバルシェイプやとかね
もう四角いとかね そうあるはずがないでしょうに
一つ答えがはっきりあるんです
だからコンディショナル
いわゆる条件付きの答えっていうのは
まあ仮に一時的に まあ一応ものはあまりトラブルを起こさないで
なんとかごまかすために使うんであって
アンコンディショナルレスポンスというのはもう絶対的答えなんです
というか 答えは一つしかない
2足す 2 だったら 4 という風に答えるしかないんです
あ  2 たす 2 は 1 から 10 までどちらでもいいんだよと
あれは 2 たす 2 だから 2 以上どちらでもいいんだよと言ってもね
それは答えにならないんです
あの数学ではね それはね
より大きいと  2 たす 2 はより大きい 2 というふうに答えられますけどね
だからそれでも数学というのはいい加減でわかるでしょうに
それで分析する場合は
草の束は美味しいですかということ
この草って何でしょうかと
この聞いてる草の束がはっきりしなくちゃいけないんですよ
この草の束 あちらにある草の束とか
それがないと答えちゃうとものすごくアホなんですよ
草の束美味しい まあこれってちょっとよくわからないとかね
何について答えてるんですかね
それでもやられるでしょ
出しちゃうとみんなもうあれ何でしょうかとか考えたりするんですけど
それでもうはめた はめられてるんですよ
これは本当は現代的な禅問答なんです
草の束美味しいですかという線の公案はないんだから
私は勝手に作ったんです
まあ自慢するために私は作れますよと
だからこのそれって牛にとっては美味しいでしょうと言ったら
これどんな草の束のことを言ってますかね
牛にしても どんな草も食べるわけないでしょうに
食べないものもありますよ
だからアンコンディショナル
いわゆる条件ない絶対的な答えを見つける人は
これはどんな草の束のことでしょうかと
それははっきりとアイデンティファイするんですよ
それは具体的に把握しなくてはならないんです
動かなくなった 次のセクションが草の束ということは
こういうふうに具体化するんですね
2番目のセクションは美味しいですかというプレディケートなんですね
それから美味しいですかってどういうことかと分析するんです
美味しいですかっていうこと
意味は何ですかね 美味しいとは
味覚に対する良いという評価でしょうし
ここで味覚を聞いてるんですよ
美味しいですかっていうことで
我々は別に評価を聞いてるではなくて
質問の中では味覚は何ですかと聞いてるんです
だから正しく言えば こちらなるこの草の束の味覚はなんですかと聞いてる質問なんです
そういうことで 質問をちゃんと分析してみなくちゃいけないんです
味覚とは その能力がある生命の主観になるんです
それで味覚といえば定義があるんですよ
味覚っていうのは その能力ある味
味を感じる能力ある一切の生命が行う判断なんですよ
だから味覚とは味覚能力を持っている生命の主観ですということになります
それでも分析終わりましたから
答えを見いだすことは簡単です
ですから 味覚がある生命の主観が答えになります
味覚がある生命一人一人に聞いてみるんです
ですから 答えはこれになるんです
あれってあの プラクティカルって何でしたっけ？まあ
インポッシブルというプラクティカルって日本語で何といいますかね
実際  実際的にはちょっと無理ですね
ですから答えはあるんだけど
まあこれだとということになるんです
あることは確かにあるんです
分析が終わってから再び組み合わせてみるんです
ここでいう草という品物が自分で味という性質を持っているんです
そこではっきりした草がありまして
そちらが味という性質を持っているんです
その原因によって生命に味覚が生じるんです
草に何か性質があるんですよ
だからそれ食べて舐めてみると
生命に味という味覚が生まれるんですよ
だから味覚が結果で この草の束を持っている性質が原因なんです
それで原因と結果のお話が話になるんです
それに我々知っている世界では
各生命の味覚はバラバラですね
主観です それは決して条件がつかない答えにはならないんです
ですから 牛もうチャート作って
まああの牛は美味しいと言うんだと
この牛はもう一度も自然のものを食べたことがないんだから
あの科学品 何といいますか
肥料と言わないね あの飼料を食べているんだから
こいつはまずいと言ってますよとかね
そういう風に取ってみても
あんまり条件付き答えにはなりません
それは無数無数の答えになるだけでね
では 知るべきなのは 草が持っている味というのは何でしょうかということ
まあそれもっとわかりやすくします
言葉はちょっと難しくなってますから
例えば この草の束が差別しないんですよ
すごい平等です 誰が食ったってもね
全然虫がこうして いや
まずくしてやるぞとかね
人間人間食べようとしてるんだから
これ超まずくしてやるぞと
草の束はそんな努力何もしません
あ 可愛い山羊さんが食べようとして
じゃあおいしくしてやるぞとかね
ということで 草の束が平等で
自分の持っている味という性質をはっきりと持っていて
それを与えているんです
だから我々は山羊にどう感じるか
牛にどう感じるかではなくて
この草の束が持っている味という性質
それはないとは言えませんよ
だって噛んだら何か感じますからね
味という性質があるんです
それは何なのかと調べなくちゃいけないんです
それが客観的な答えになります
それを知るために 語るために
私は主観のない知力を持たなくてはならないんです
大変なことになります
私は噛んでみて あ こんな味と言っちゃうと
これ私の主観でしょうに
だから私は答えたければ
私が主観のない知力 知る能力を持たなくちゃいけないんです
いわゆる私には 物事を客観的に知る能力をついてないとダメなんです
残念なことに 何を見ても主観なんです
何を聞いても主観なんです
何を嗅いでみても主観なんです
何を味わってみても主観なんです
何を体に触れてみたっても
それが主観なんです それから何を考えても
それがその人の主観なんです
それかそれが破らない限り
あの草が持っている味という性質を発見できません
したがって 条件がつかない唯一の答えが
主観を破った真理に達した人のみが知っているんです
だから 人に主観がある限り
その問答には答えられないんです
たった一つの答えがあるんです
それは主観がある限り
もう知る世界じゃないんです
超えています ということは
正しい答えは一般人の管轄外なんです
だから やたらに草の束美味しいですかと聞かれたっても
やたらに答えない方がいいんです
これは管轄外なんです
だから あの禅五六なんかはね
犬に仏性ありやとかね
いろいろあるでしょうに
これバカが答えとするんですよ
こんなもうやたらに誰にでも答える公安ではないんです
このように全くくだらない例を用いても
真理の世界 真理の境地を指すことができるんです
私はあえてくだらない問答を作ったんです
草の束美味しいですかと聞いただけでもバカバカらしいでしょうに
しかし その中から我々の真理は
真理の世界 いわゆる悟りの境地を示すことはできるんです
あり合わせで真理に達することができるということなんです
こんな大変なことをしなくたっても
何を見ても その中からブッダが語る真理の世界を示すことができるんです
その一つのやり方ですけど
大体禅世界ではまあその側面でよく頑張ってはいるんです
はい  それで一つのセクションが終わりました